[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute gibt es ein ganz
einfaches rezept denn ich mache heute
heute eine wort passt also das heißt ich
mache heute nudelgericht in einem topf
bzw in einer pfanne mache ich das jetzt
die nudeln müssen vorher nicht abgekocht
werden ich schmeiße alles direkt in eine
pfanne schließt den deckel und dann muss
das ganze 20 minuten lang köcheln also
das ist praktisch so dass ein ganz
einfaches rezept was auch jeder
nachmachen kann und es ist auch gerade
total im trend dieser walcott gerichte
also wenn ihr da gerne auch noch rezepte
habe dich mal nachmachen soll schreibt
mir einfach ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal kurz die zutaten das reicht für etwa
drei bis vier personen je nachdem wie
viel ihr halt ist bei uns vielleicht für
2 bis 3 ich brauche spaghetti also ihr
können auch andere nudeln nehmen ich
habe jetzt ein spaghetti beziehungsweise
bei wetten dass und zwar 350 gramm 900
milliliter wasser vier esslöffel
olivenöl eine zwiebel und 2
knoblauchzehen ich habe ich eine
handvoll basilikum aus von meiner
terrasse gepflückt hier habe ich 200
gramm cocktailtomaten drei esslöffel
tomatenmark einen esslöffel balsamico
creme eine prise zucker eine kleine
chilischote und so ein paar getrocknete
tomaten die sind in öl eingelegt und ich
brauchen natürlich noch salz pfeffer und
ich nehm tropische oregano nämlich jetzt
getrocknet start auch mal einfach direkt
es gebe jetzt die spaghettis
das war jetzt 500 nahmen 350 gebe ich in
die pfanne bin jetzt eine panne hat sie
groß genug ist können dass sie so
komplett reinlegen gibt ja auch so
eckige pfannen oder so wie ich jetzt ich
muss jetzt halt einmal durchbrechen
damit sie hier reinpassen
dann nehme ich die zwiebel und die
knoblauchzehe und würfeln die bei der
zwiebel müsst ihr aufpassen beim schälen
das da vorne die wurzel schönen
zusammenbleibt weil dann fällt die auch
beim schneiden gleich nicht auseinander
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die knoblauchzehe scheidig in feine
scheiben könnte aber auch würfeln wie
ihr wollt könnt ihr auch fein reiben
[Musik]
das kommt jetzt auch direkt mit rein
also normalerweise hätte ich sie jetzt
vielleicht sogar formal erst mal mit dem
öl angebraten
da kommt diese röstaromen hatte sich
halten wollen trotz gericht deswegen
machen wir auch alles in einem durchgang
dann olivenöl wenn das wasser gebe ich
jetzt auch gleich mit dazu
ich mache jetzt erstmal nur so 800
milliliter und den recht kann ich ja
dann immer noch dazu geben die
cherrytomaten die nehme ich jetzt hier
runter und die werde ich jetzt gleich
vierter
[Musik]
wenn ihr die tomaten übrigens nur
halbieren wollt müsst das ja auch so
einem flachen teller legen und zweiten
teller darüber legen dann könnte ein
messer durchfahren
dann habt ihr den einem zug halbiert
aber spiele zu viert
[Musik]
dann kommt auch direkt tomatenmark mit
rein
[Musik]
die getrockneten tomaten die nehme ich
immer gerne in öl eingelegt weil sie
ansonsten sehr trocken sind dann müsste
das sie vorher zum beispiel wenn er sie
so hoch sagt jetzt noch verwendet muss
dass wir vorher nochmal abkochen damit
sie weich werden jetzt für dieses
gericht würden sie auch komplett
getrocknet gehen weil die weichen mit
dem gericht zusammen auf das öl hätte
ich jetzt übrigens auch benutzen können
also statt olivenöl einfach jetzt dieses
öl das ist schön gewürzt das schmeiße
ich auch nie weg sondern benutzt es
meistens dann noch weiter es sind ja
schön die ganzen aromen mit drin liegt
auch immer so ein lorbeerblatt mit drin
[Musik]
ziemlich blöd aus aber die sind halt
fertigstellen
ich wollte in die hand nehmen so dass
auch mit rein dann auch direkt die
balsamico also dieses rezept habe ich
selber auch noch immer aber das klingt
schon ziemlich schnell
[Musik]
diese zucker physisch immer gut bei
tomaten gericht hebt den tomaten
geschmack dann noch die chilischote die
muss jetzt natürlich nicht sein ich als
schülerin ganz kaputt ich mir das ganze
ein bisschen und dann gebe ich noch die
basilikumblätter die gebe ich so
schlecht reingekommen dass man noch zum
schluss jetzt gebe ich hier noch oregano
rhein-main ich bin nicht dass dies
basilikumblätter zu zerfallen und würzt
das gleich mit pfeffer und auch etwas
salz und jetzt riecht ist ein bisschen
durch
[Musik]
aber das geht gleich besser wenn wir das
gleich aufkochen jetzt lasse ich erst
einmal aufkochen und dann rühren wir es
gleich durch insgesamt braucht das ganze
jetzt etwa 20 minuten
ich stelle es jetzt erstmal auf höchster
stufe schaltern auf mittlerer stufe und
früher dann immer wieder zwischendurch
um damit das ganze sich auch schön
vermischt und dann sehen wir uns gleich
in 20 minuten wieder
[Musik]
jetzt alle fünf minuten das mal umgehört
und das weil wir insgesamt zweimal also
einmal direkt am anfang als jetzt noch
gesehen hat einmal zwischendrin und
jetzt und ich habe jetzt nach 15 minuten
bereits so weit dass der al dente sind
das heißt ich brauche es jetzt nicht
mehr weiter kochen lassen und ich habe
auch noch die 100 milliliter wasser
übrig also müsste einfach je nach
nudelsorten natürlich auch schauen wie
lange deshalb braucht aber ich bin auch
zufrieden sind machen viertelstunde
schon fertig ist ich muss noch bis nach
sachsen habe ich gemerkt und das gibt
auch den deckel geöffnet damit einfach
noch so ein bisschen die feuchtigkeit
weg geht
jetzt nehme ich mir noch die
basilikumblätter und zupfte hier rein
können natürlich auch fein hacken
aber ich mag was silikone und es darf
bei mir schon ganz gut mit rein bin ich
halt wirklich so alle fünf minuten
ansonsten kann es passieren dass unten
am topfboden alles leben bleibt vor
allem am anfang muss er auch die
spaghetti schlüssel auseinander genommen
werden sonst lägen die alle zusammen
für mich sieht es jetzt echt perfekt aus
vor allem ich das jetzt echt eine
richtig schöne soße
[Musik]
was ich bin gerade selber bisserl
überrascht wie gut das geklappt hat
basilikumblätter und dann hole ich mir
gleich meinen pasta teller und kanten
schön anrichten
der vorteil an diesem rezept ist einfach
auch die soße klebt hat richtig gut an
den nudeln als hat die soße nicht
überall dran und das sieht so lecker aus
und ich hab's ja eben schon probiert das
ist auch wirklich sehr lecker meiner
meinung nach natürlich zu wenig chili
ich würde es gleich noch lebt hier noch
bissl panische andere natürlich immer
frisch gerieben haben noch zwei
basilikum blätter
[Musik]
und dann habt ihr innerhalb von 15
minuten dieses leckere pasta gerichte
gezaubert
zumindest optisch gezaubert ihr könnt
sie nachmachen ich schreib doch mal die
genauen mengenangaben auf meinem blog
auf zehn.de und wenn ihr das nachmacht
dann freue ich mich natürlich auch über
fotos es geht wirklich total schnell
ganz einfach alles in einer pfanne und
deckel drauf und fertig und mir gefällt
es richtig gut wenn ihr wollt mache ich
gern noch weitere sofort rezepte dann
schreibt es mir einfach in die
kommentare rein und ich freue mich schon
wieder auf nächste mal bis dann
[Musik]
natur ganz normal